Hello.
My name is Reto Meier, and
welcome to "This Week in
Android Development" on Monday,
October 7, 2013.
An unfortunate incident
involving a mirror universe
prevented the broadcast of
"This Week in Android
Development" for the
last two weeks.
But thankfully, my goatee-clad
evil twin is just as
passionate about making data
transfers more efficient,
delivering the final two
episodes in the series,
covering variable update
frequencies
and minimizing payloads.
Undisturbed by the implications
of the
intersection of multiple planes
of existence, Trevor
Jones also delivered a DevByte
on Network Service Discovery,
while intern Daniel delivered
his final DevByte describing
how to expand cells
within list views.
With alternative worlds already
colliding, Todd
Kopelman continues to offer
advice for mobile developers
with a slightly different
focus with his series of
DevBytes covering Google Play
Game Services for iOS, with
episodes on using sign-in
buttons and introducing REST.
Meanwhile, in New York and
London, Nick, Roman, and Adam
covered the onboarding
experience and collection
design in two all new episodes
of "Android Design in Action."
Back here in sunny Mountain
View, Todd and the Wolff Man
were back in action in "Game
On!" introducing management
tools and graphs.
We also launched "Admin Tool and
Utilities for Google Play
Game Services." And for those of
you that prefer a good book
over watching TV, check out
this new guide to managing
device awake state.
In ecosystem news, we saw the
proportion of Android devices
running Jelly Bean nearly
hitting 50%.
Coming up this week, Todd
continues his series helping
iOS developers get up to speed
on Play Game Services.
And Bruno and Neto present a
very special edition of "Game
On!" in Portuguese.
That's all for "This Week in
Android Development." Be sure
to check out this
week's Bytes.
I'm Reto Meier, and I'll
leave you with
these parting questions.
You want to live fancy?
Live in a big mansion?
Party in France?